a federal appeals court is blocking a
new york prosecutor from obtaining
president trump's tax returns while the
president's lawyers
continue to fight a subpoena seeking the
records the three-judge panel ruled
after hearing brief arguments from both
sides the president's lawyers
had asked for a temporary stay while
they appealed the lower court ruling
granting manhattan district attorney
cyrus vance junior's office
access to his tax returns a lawyer for
vance's office had argued
further delays would only impede his
investigation fox news has learned house
speaker nancy pelosi visited a san
francisco hair salon
yesterday for a wash and blow out
despite local ordinances keeping salons
closed amid the coronavirus pandemic
security footage obtained by fox news
time stamped monday 3
0 pm pacific shows pelosi walking
through east salon in san francisco
with wet hair and without a mask over
her mouth or nose pelosi spokesman
drew hamill maintains the speaker was
following the rules
quote the speaker always wears a mask
and complies with local coveted
requirements however the owner
called the whole incident a quote slap
in the face
let's go in depth on the presidential
race tonight here in pennsylvania
joining us
vice president mike pence thanks for
joining us good to see you brett
obviously you have a lot of supporters
here you see fertile ground in
pennsylvania
[Applause]
a lot of enthusiasm on the ground you
know
joe biden's boyhood home is not far from
where we're seated but this is trump
country now brett
and i think it's because of the choice
in this election in president donald
trump
the people of pennsylvania see someone
who's kept all the promises that he made
we rebuild our military we revive the
economy through less taxes less
regulation
more american energy we stood by the
right to life and religious liberty
and joe biden by contrast despite his
heritage in this area
now leads a party that i think has been
overtaken by the radical
left they want higher taxes socialized
medicine
open borders abortion on demand and
actually want to cut
funding to law enforcement what i saw
here today
what i saw on the road the way here is
that
we're going to win four more years for
president donald trump in the white
house you know vice president biden was
here in pennsylvania yesterday he said
among other things does anyone believe
there'll be less violence in america if
donald trump is reelected how did you
take that
well i didn't know how to take it to be
honest with you
yesterday we heard joe biden kind of
you know mouth words against violence
in the streets but then he very quickly
criticized law enforcement
he described an unwarranted police
shooting while an investigation is still
going on
he never mentioned antifa he never
mentioned
the radical left mobs that have been
tearing asunder and setting fire to many
of our major cities
over the last three months and i think
what what
the american people know and they saw it
today in kenosha with president trump's
visit there
is we have a president today who is
going to stand for law and order we're
going to stand with the men and women of
law enforcement
we're going to give them the resources
and support they need and we're going to
continue to call
on governors and mayors to do their
job and restore order in the cities
where we've seen the kind of violence
that we've seen
over the last several months here's more
from your predecessor
former vice president but this is a
sitting president
of the united states of america he's
supposed to be protecting his country
but instead he's rooting for chaos and
violence
the simple truth is donald trump failed
to protect america
so now he's trying to scare america
trying to scare america well
i i think that's the kind of rhetoric
that people here in pennsylvania and
around the country see
straight through i mean what the
american people are concerned
about are these left-wing mobs
that have been allowed to run roughshod
in places like portland
and new york and seattle and over the
last several days
in kenosha i mean look there there's
you know you know there's no excuse for
what happened to george floyd months ago
and justice will be served
but there's also no excuse for the
rioting and the looting and the violence
that has followed and the american
people know they have a president
who is going to demand that governors
and mayors in these democrat-run cities
and these democrat states
step up do their job restore law
and order and that's really the choice
that we have you didn't mention jacob
blake there
well jacob blake that's that's a a
tragic situation that's under
investigation today
it well it's shot seven times and and
you know we we grieve an incident like
that we really do
but i want to let the investigation play
out it's remarkable that joe biden
yesterday
announced that it was an unwarranted
police shooting before we have all the
facts in but
frankly if you look at the last
administration
joe biden and barack obama often
reflexively criticized
law enforcement it's one of the reasons
why in the last campaign
president trump enjoyed so much support
from law enforcement because we're
we're going to follow the facts justice
will be served in every case we have
poor violence in any circumstances
but we're not going to reflexively
condemn law enforcement
president trump his vice president our
administration
are going to stand with the men and
women of law enforcement we're going to
let investigations proceed
to justice served speaking of facts
we're trying to get to the bottom of
this story that the president has now
told twice to reporters that a person
was on a plane
said there were six people dressed in
black
uh filled with looters rioters
anarchists
people looking for trouble do you know
what he's talking about well i think
what the president's referring to
is is actually what uh what we heard in
many of the cities
that i know in detroit there were a
large number of arrests several weeks
ago
and the vast majority of people were
from out of state
the same thing the same thing occurred
in arrests that took place
uh in recent cities i mean we look
there's something going on here
where the radical left these anarchists
and antifa
are moving people around the country and
it's one of the reasons that the justice
department is looking into
where where is the funding for this
coming from i think
the american people can see what's
happening or a charge against anybody
funding this i mean it's been going on
for some time
we haven't seen any antifa arrests or
you know people tied with the funding of
this operation well that's actually not
right brett we've actually
the justice department has overseen
about 300 arrests well specifically but
not
since the violence has broken out in
cities around the country and
we're going to continue to lean into
that effort we're going to make sure the
american people know that we're going to
work closely on the organic state
officials and law enforcement side but
we're
we're vigorously investigating where
this is being organized from i remember
i remember when the when the the
rioting and the setting fire of
buildings in washington dc was taking
place
we actually heard that some organization
was pre-positioning
assets and resources around the
city and so i i think people can see
this is
an organized effort in part some of it
may be spontaneous
and the radical left certainly has its
adherence in in every city in the
country
but uh but we're we're looking to the
justice department to get to the bottom
of it
i want to turn to to covet in a second
but i want to fact check another thing
the president tweeted out today
it never ends now they're trying to say
your favorite president me went to
walter reed medical center having
suffered a series of many strokes never
happened to this candidate fake news
fake news perhaps they're referring to
another candidate
from another party this refers to
michael schmidt's book where he says the
president went to walter reed which in
fact happened in november of last year
he says in the book that you were put on
alert to take
control to take office essentially if he
went
under for anesthesia is that true
president donald trump is in excellent
health
and brett i'm always informed of the
president's movements
and uh whether it was on that day or any
other day
uh i'm informed but there was no there
was nothing out of the ordinary
about that moment or or that day and i
just refer any other questions to the
white house physician but as far as
being on standby
i don't i don't recall being told to be
on standby
i i was informed that the president had
a doctor's appointment
and uh uh i don't want to say i must say
but i just want to yeah i got i got to
tell you and
part of this job is you're always on
standby as your vice president of the
united states
um but uh the american people can be
confident that
um this president is in remarkable good
health and uh
every single day i see that energy in
high relief i want to talk about covid
in hindsight do you think the lockdowns
were a mistake
i don't i really do believe that
when the president made the decision to
suspend all travel from
china when he stood up the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
when we asked the american people for
what became 45 days to slow the spread i
think we
saved countless lives and those
lockdowns permitted us
to stand up literally
billions of supplies to our doctors and
nurses and hospitals around the country
manufactured more than a hundred
thousand ventilators
in less than a hundred days uh and uh
and
i really do believe the sacrifices the
american people made during that time
made it possible for us to ensure that
no american who required a ventilator
was ever denied a ventilator our doctors
and nurses had the ppe that they
required
we were able to reinvent testing to
where we're doing 800
000 tests a day more to come with the
announcements of
this last week and ultimately it put us
in a place where
every single day i think we're one day
closer to the day we have that vaccine
in addition to the therapeutics that we
have and we put this coronavirus in the
past you did a lot but i guess i was
asking whether you look back and could
have done something different we learned
a lot as the virus was continuing as did
you
you were the head of the coronavirus
task force r uh
you've talked out about wearing masks
and social distancing
take a listen wear a mask
when whenever your state and local
authorities say it's appropriate
uh so where it's always a good idea to
wear a mask when social distancing
is not possible what further evidence
does anyone need
that this president doesn't care less
about the spread
of this virus than to see what he did
vandalizing by the way the white house
by bringing all those people there no
mask
no distancing and the rest he slapped
science right in the face
talking about the speech there on the
south lawn no mass
no distance but that's kind of what you
were saying all along
respond if you would to the house
speaker well i i
appreciate the speaker's concern about
the american people but president trump
and i trust the american people
you give the people the best information
and people make
decisions uh in what they believe is
most appropriate to their health that
that setting at the white house was not
only inspiring but we also provided
mass anyone that wanted one with hand
cleaners and sanitizers
but what's remarkable to me is that that
nancy pelosi had to my knowledge not a
word to say
about the gathering that took place
outside the lincoln memorial the next
day
i mean literally thousands and thousands
of americans
all gathered but i would say in both
cases
the american people were exercising
those god-given rights enshrined in our
constitution to peaceably assemble
we did it on the south lawn on thursday
night and we did it
they did it outside the lincoln memorial
on friday and
and and i really do believe that it's it
is a choice between many
uh in the democratic party that simply
want want once again to
tell the american people what to do and
a president and
a team in the white house that really
trusts the american people
to put the health of themselves their
families and our country first
your now opponent senator kamala harris
tweeted this nearly 183 000 americans
have died from coronavirus more than 16
million
out of work students across the country
can't go back to campus
more than 110 000 small businesses
closed for good
this is trump's america how do you
respond to that
well there's not a day goes by that i
don't think of the families that have
lost loved ones
brett as i said in pennsylvania today
more than 7 000 americans in this state
passed away and i wanted those families
to know that they'll always be in our
hearts
and in our prayers but i have no doubt
in my mind
that had president trump not suspended
all travel from china
before we had a single case of community
transmission
in in this country had had he not stood
up the white house coronavirus task
force had we not suspended travel
from other countries and then used that
time working with the american people
45 days to slow the spread provided
nearly 4 trillion
in relief to businesses that that has
now created a foundation where in the
last three months we've already seen
nine
million americans go back to work i
think the combination of all of those
for fair-minded americans looking on
they know that this is a president who
has led us
through one of the most challenging
times in my lifetime and he's led in a
way that put the health of america first
last time you faced senator tim kaine
here's a little piece of that from your
debate
donald trump supports our veterans he
won't pay taxes donald
trump has paid all the taxes that he's
do you not take details
how does that work americans need to
worry about whether donald trump will be
watching out for america's bottom line
or his own bottom line
so it's a different person you're facing
in kamala harris but along the taxes
line
why haven't the american people seen the
president's taxes
you know at first there was years of he
was it was under an audit
now his lawyers are spending a lot of
time fighting a subpoena by the
manhattan district attorney to try to
get the taxes
why not put him out ahead of this
election well the president's responded
to that many times
and as i said in that very same debate
you know the president literally has
produced
hundreds of pages of financial
disclosures which is what the law
requires but you know different than the
time i was sitting for that
debate and today the american people
actually voted
four years ago to elect donald trump to
be president of the united states so you
think that ends that issue uh well look
i i i think
at the at the end of the day the
american people are are
more concerned about their bottom line
and their income than about
the income of the president of the
united states i i really believe that
when you look at the fact that in our
first three years
because this president kept his word to
the people of pennsylvania
we cut taxes for businesses large and
small and working families
we rolled back more regulation than any
administration in american history
we unleashed american energy so that
states like pennsylvania now are part of
an american energy renaissance i mean
joe biden
actually has repeatedly said that that
his administration would abolish
fossil fuels now i know he said
yesterday that that
i'm not banning frackling fracking but
that flies in the face of what he has
said
over and over and over again
over the past year look at their agenda
his version of the green new deal
they'll make good on it
joe biden and the democratic party have
been overtaken by the radical left
as an agenda to abolish american energy
i think the enthusiasm you saw in
pennsylvania today
tells you that this president's
commitment to less taxes
more jobs more american energy is going
to be a winning message
in pennsylvania i've got to hit a break
and i could talk to you all day with a
lot of questions but two very quick ones
one
will you assure will the president
assure that there's not a government
shutdown
and is it possible that the coronavirus
bill whatever it is
is going to be tied to that effort well
we're continuing to have discussions
with leaders in congress about another
coronavirus relief bill
and i can tell you nobody wants to send
more support to american families and
businesses than president
donald trump but we're not going to
allow
democrats in congress so the government
will use a coronavirus bill to
to basically bail out badly run democrat
states around the country we're going to
stand
firm but the president's looking at a
variety of options we're going to bring
the american people
through this challenging time we're
going to be there to support families
support businesses and we're going to
bring america all the way back
with four more years of president donald
trump mr vice president we appreciate
the time you've been in the broadcasting
business i've got to hit a break
thank you very much it's been great to
have you here